a team of US negotiators is in North
Korea this morning they are still trying
to prepare for a possible June 12th
summit with Kim jong-un even after
President Trump abruptly canceled it
last week the president praised North
Korea on Twitter yesterday riding I
truly believe North Korea has brilliant
potential and will be a great economic
and financial nation one day Ben Tracy
is just back from North Korea he's
following the talks from Beijing then
good morning good morning so there are
now two delegations of Americans meeting
with their North Korean counterparts one
set of meetings taking place in North
Korea the other is a delegation sent to
Singapore to work on logistics and it is
increasingly clear that both President
Trump and Kim jong-eun want this summit
to happen so we're looking at June 12th
in Singapore that hasn't changed the
on-again off-again summit appears to be
on again but this weekend it was Kim
jong-un and South Korean president moon
jae-in who met for a surprise summit of
their own their second meeting in less
than 30 days they met for two hours on
the North Korean side of the
demilitarized zone North Korean state
media says that at the meeting Kim Jong
moon expressed his fixed will that the
summit with president Trump take place
briefing reporters in Seoul on Sunday
president moon revealed that Kim also
said that he is still committed to the
complete denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula but in the past that offer has
come with a North Korean demand that the
u.s. pull out it's more than 28 thousand
troops stationed on the peninsula and
ended security commitments with South
Korea and Japan former Director of
National Intelligence James clapper
unfazed the nation North Koreans could
assert that we have a responsibility to
denuclearize and restrict our nuclear
umbrella meaning no beam winds b-2s or
b-52s flying into the korean Finnis
landing in the korean peninsula or an
operational proximity
North Koreans feel they have showed good
faith by claiming to blow up their only
known nuclear test site last week we
were among a small group of journalists
invited in to witness the explosions
this is tunnel number three at North
Korea's nuclear test site and they say
this tunnel is relatively new that it's
still usable so rigging it with
explosives and blowing it up to them is
a real concession at their meeting this
weekend South Korea's president told Kim
jong-eun that if he does fully give up
his nuclear weapons that the United
States would provide his regime with a
security guarantee and what he called
economic cooperation Vlad then Tracy in
Beijing thank you